You've initialized your scene with lights, objects and a camera. Naturally, the
next step is to render. If you look through an entire Three.js program you've
seen this line, telling the renderer class to render the scene. It's possible
to call the renderer once during initialization and be done, but usually we
want to have the scene be updated as needed. Once the scene is set up, calling
the animate function gets things rolling. The key bit of magic is the
window.requestAnimationFrame call, which in turn uses the animate method
itself. This method will start up a rendering whenever it makes sense to do so.
The other thing that requestAnimationFrame does for you is help lower the
temperature of your computer. No, really. Say you have a webGL program running
in a browser window. If you switch to another tab, the browser will know that
the program is no longer visible and it will not keep it running. The animate
method calls the render method to well, render the scene. Actually, it can do
much more than that. I like to separate out the render method itself just to
keep track of what's doing what. This method is where you want to put code that
performs changes before rendering the scene. For example, if the user modifies
the slider, the slider's value is used here to modify the scene. We've seen
that in previous programs. If you have a bouncing ball animation, you change
the position of the ball here. This is where animation gets going.